there's the hourly blitz arena going on
57 minute long tournament 36 minutes
left i'm gonna join and i'm gonna try
and win it
what to do
okay first game playing sheila edie all
the zerk
um anyone below let's say 1800 i'm
berserking against
hello to more people
welcome everyone
we're starting out with a
folk beer counter gambit against the
king's gambit
yeah e4
so
[Music]
i'm temporarily not a pawn the point of
this move is to restrict the knight
and
get a bit more space in the center
i have six if d3 i'll play bishop to b4
if that i'll play this
already maybe some idea of going in for
the kill
[Music]
but i do have to
kind of babysit the pawn so for everyone
just joining i've late joined this
hourly blitz arena this is my first game
of the stream and of the tournament
i am tied for last place
the goal is to finish in first place
might be difficult because the time
control is three plus two
uh when i berserk i do lose increment
but opponents taking their sweet sweet
time oh how did the marathon go
yeah i only played
last night
i'll play
let's play this move first
developing with tempo
wasn't sure about e3 there
it looked interesting the e3 there was
d4
yeah now
um
i'll take
so the nice thing is i'm preventing
white from castling
i also just played queen e7 to prevent
bishop e3
that's slightly annoying move
if i play this or is this
bishop d7
i want to play c6 and eventually
complete development
it's castle
c6
white's actually playing pretty well
here
so if we trade wow does this move
okay so oh no both of our queens
the problem for white is the rook kings
and now i'm up
oh i'm up a minor piece and a rook
or a pawn
so that was a pretty good trade for me
i think you robbed katan subbing for two
months
okay so now hitting the pawn
uh the goal is to win quickly
so even in a position like this which is
completely completely winning
i want to accelerate
the speed of which i win
if king c2 maybe b5 b4 okay let's grab
this pawn uh bring the knight in
i'd like to orchestrate some mating
attack
i'll play this move
oh there's a funny line i'm gonna play
this and say oh no my rook
oh no my rook oh no my bishop ah i hung
everything
okay so the point is after it takes
bishop here
and it's a funny bishop mate
that wasn't objectively the best move
but it was the funniest
it was the funniest line
as maybe the quickest way to end the
game
thank you lee seven live
okay
moving up in the world top 50
hi eric 31 million always enjoy when you
play low-rated players because it gives
me ideas for my own games oh that's nice
here uh
what do i play against carol khan let's
play a hillbilly
thank you s price a thousand bits
first time chatter
okay so the hillbilly
where i sacked e pawn
it's one of the most aggressive but also
dubious lines against the caro khan
now maybe i could have chosen a safer
but still aggressive line but
okay it's hard to get more aggressive
than this
black normally we'll play this or this
and then f3
so the point is i want to trade off the
e pawn develop the knight
and then open that file
because someday i want to castle
and the queen finds a happy place
on each floor
yeah so i didn't berserk this game
because it's very risky to
give away the increments
but i'm still making an effort to play
quickly
still in some opening prep too
i'm not too concerned about the
discoveries
this is maybe a playable move but
probably walks into
oh queen g3 there's bishop h4
so i would have to be a little bit
careful
but now i'm controlling h4
and the queen might eventually slide
back to h3
and target the g
pawn uh
that's a decent move
so this is a threat d3 doesn't really
help
it's actually a good move
i was thinking queen g3 but i lose g2 in
the end
so
let's play e5
it's a bit risky
i idea queen f4
i want to play d4 remove the knight from
defending the other knight
in the event of g5 i might have to play
this i'm not sure how useful g5 was for
black because the queen is maybe a bit
happier here
now it's clear black's not castling
but now it's my opponent who's playing
ultra
aggressively uh wow bishop g5 is maybe
coming
so i have d4
who's this move
oh that was actually very clever hello
eric hello good to see you
i kind of just want a castle
good to see you too
it's already like really weird position
if i play
d4 doesn't quite work
does it
i don't think it does d3 is interesting
i think i'll play d3
so i'm calculating uh takes takes takes
here check key two
looks really ugly
but i would win back the pawn
okay bishop d2
queen a5 is a welcome surprise
i think my opponent was thinking they
could take and win this pawn but
not happening yeah my goal is to stay as
focused as possible on the tournament
games
uh 27 minutes left
it's going to be hard to win because
games could potentially take a while
[Music]
uh yeah i couldn't take the queen
because queen would be reborn
oh
bishop here probably holding on to the
pawn
bishop h4 i still play king e2
looks like a reasonable blonde cloud
okay now i have a file a7 is a bit
tender
not that i want to take it
oh i love you too
thank you dobber
[Music]
gob i really want a counter attack here
like rook g7
[Music]
or even allow
the i think i have to play this move
kind of a sad move because allowing this
okay five i guess he three
not quite what i want but okay the game
keeps going
now i can take
i have to be really really careful
that's a greedy move but bishop is now
hanging
[Music]
wait this doesn't work at all
[Music]
or does it
oh no
don't hurt me
i'm in trouble things are hanging
i'm not sure how bad it is though it's
probably really bad
but okay black's getting low on time
a messy position this is hanging this is
hanging king's really naked
now the thing is defended the rook's
attacked
oh
that was a good move
play rook g4
also queen a4
[Music]
doesn't quite work
not to do this
the emperor wears no clothes
oh no my emperor
i'm referring to my king
[Music]
i don't know what to do here
maybe this move
and this move
is covering the checks
i'm in big trouble here
when in doubt gambit the king for peace
activity i know that's why i'm trying
i hide
on b5
almost missed a free bishop
super messy game
hey it's mate okay oh what a game man
all that work for one reading point
oh man
okay
i was probably getting mated by forcer
wow
good thing i didn't berserk
so i have five tournament points
leader has 12.
thank you stephen gray
the [ __ ] king is very flexible yeah i
was doing the split stack game
i'll have to analyze that because i'm
pretty sure black had force made
somewhere
i'll play e4 again
uh i'm going to play a grand prix attack
against the piers
that's one of the aggressive options
welcome back icelander chess noob
and thank you
crater's gonna prate
so this is a pretty typical
groundbreaking content
could we get a ross gambit a ross gambit
like rossa boss
getting mated by connect eight
oh rasa boss is here hey
rossa boss says a i love the grand prix
also thank you robert
joseph
okay so my goal is this this
this this this
oh black has goals too
[Music]
thankfully f2 is covered
e3 also kind of covered
playlist first
i vote we change the rules of chess so
that the only mates that count now are
made by connect 8.
then
then there wouldn't be too many mates
those would be a
that would be a fun rule change
or mape i connect four
okay so i'm losing a pawn
um
it seems like there's compensation here
and black wants to eat my pawns
i'm offering
so if h5 g4
or this is mate okay
that was pleasant
opponent was defending until
they weren't defending
so 10 points
four points out of first
all these people playing games
oh okay
let's go for a
stafford
or not a stafford
opponent is playing a danish
so the line i like to play against okay
danish or goring
is i decline the gamut with d5
a striking in the center
and
ooh
that's actually a move can take
so
we trade queens i'm up upon
uh maybe i could have gone out of my way
to keep queens on the board but
i don't mind having the material
advantage
develop
by f5
some idea to play f4 already
f4 would force bishop d4 never mind
really close to trapping the bishop
so i play c5 to prepare f4
still preparing f4
i mean if g3
i'll play bishop a6
here i can finally trap the bishop
okay
now it still takes some work
bishop's a little bit awkward
maybe this move
so i'm losing the pawn losing one of
these pawns
or both
wait i can't count oh i already moved my
king
oh i tried castling queenside but my
king moved already because we traded
queens and then i moved back
okay so i'm up a piece for two pawns
the rooks want to get involved
i think the goal is to exploit the files
pawns are like sitting ducks
or standing ducks
okay
yeah the goal is to get to the king
threatening this now bishop
f3
i'm unleashing the c file
i think the plan is to play this in this
or this
yeah so after it takes its maiden one
there we go
wasn't expecting to mate that quickly
in the ending
but white kind of walked into it
okay third place
one point on the first 16 minutes left
okay nobody's working this game playing
cachner
thank you high power
subbing for eight months
okay so playing this line
uh no stafford
i'll go for the quick g5 this is one way
to
break the symmetry
and play aggressively
um
play this move
i'll be right back my heat just came on
so the audio might be weird
thank you limbic logic
okay so the knight's pinned
oh
it's a very adventurous move
i think oh
i'll start by taking
about seven and then king of f8
there's some knight a5 and then queen e6
also have this move
maybe i can start with
i'm not only threatening the bishop but
threatening this this and then some
knight move and then queen h4 mate
a move like knight d5 is
kind of gangster
knight d5
oh no my knight can be taken three
different ways
that's all about getting the queen here
and knight d5 is more useful than other
random knight moves because i want to
get to f4
in the event of king h2 queen h4
[Music]
okay i finally have time to watch your
stream
how have you been here
i've been doing well wait i'm not
meeting
i thought i was meeting
well i guess here knight f4
and now i'm threatening takes takes and
mate
welcome back bobo baggins good to see
you
tier three for 18 months
i'm not sure how white defends
i guess there's queen d1 which is a
really sad
move
and then i'll play h5
the camel that breaks the straws back
uh yeah this gets mated
this is meat
if this is meat
hi
sinister roberts
okay that was nice
yeah this opening is fun to go for the
quick g5 could be risky but
okay it worked out
first place let's go 13 minutes left
i did late join
[Music]
so i started the stream 23 minutes ago
[Music]
i joined right at the beginning of the
stream
no more berserking try and maintain my
lead
we have a
alakine
is my opponent going to play the o
sullivan that would be funny
no sullivan i'll play mainline
thank you nasmata
gifting to
can can ep
uh playlist move
so the setup i generally like to employ
is b3 bishop b2 knight bd2
make my pieces happy defend the past
place bits
love your content ambrose and thank you
oh thanks so much
a noon cool gal
okay so this move
i have to be careful after this there's
a threat
so probably rook b1
queen c1
queen c2
actually not sure what to play here
is this uh
maybe rook c1
just ensuring
there was a pin against the pawn
now i can castle
okay so one of the ideas is to play b4
b5
and bishop c3 supports b4
kind of walks into knight e4
yeah
hmm 94 is a good move
i could move all the way back
there might be one ugly move
it's kind of
ugly think i'll play knight b1 actually
i'm okay with the trade
i wanted to keep
d4 defended
so the knight redevelops
and now my plan is probably a3 b4
wow bishop e4
[Music]
it's a good move
i might be losing a pawn here
i mean i have 94
or 95
not what i want to do but
kind of getting outplayed
yeah so i'm losing a pawn
on the bright side
i have some initiative if this i have
this
maybe f3
or t1 first
oh no i'm losing another pawn
[Music]
i have a trick
and i go for this
oh no my h pawn
and the point is after takes king h1 i'm
putting this and this
that's a good move though
maybe this move
this is start
oh man
[Music]
i didn't see that in that move
i'm in trouble
i have this move though
this move weirdly defends everything
because this isn't possible and this is
impossible
[Music]
i thought i was gonna have to lose
exchange and then cry but
we'll have to save crying for later
okay so now i can take the queen
and then take the
pawn maybe mounting a comeback
it's still a really scary position
though
someone passed me two oh no
i gotta go for activity
i have two's hanging
i push the pawn there's also this idea
i think i push the pawn
the box counter play is quick
the bishop takes i take with a rook
and a push i mate
okay somehow it's a miracle
belated christmas miracle
or a belated hanukkah miracle
okay i should probably should have lost
that game
let's go
oh calibri
is ahead of me
i probably have to berserk to catch up
are they playing oh they're not playing
we might play
if we play i don't berserk i don't think
we're playing
this game determines first place
okay
high stakes i beat this person once
before
you know f3 is a playable move but
uh
it's okay for me
i want to do things
f5
queen h4 i think queen
i think queen h4 is interesting
the idea is to provoke g3 and then just
move back
and then the light squares are a bit
weaker
and white doesn't have lightweight
bishop so
[Music]
now i can try this bits
okay
doing many things thanks stephen gray
oh there's a funny line h3
i don't think it works though because
queen g2
[Music]
that doesn't work
is this move
ah it feels wrong but let's do it
i played this move
a slightly awkward development
start with this and castle
i'm trying to figure out what my plan is
maybe this
over the rook lift
it looks kind of risky
my knight's defending f7
meaning one maybe c5
so if takes i take the knight first
and the rook and knight are both hanging
now
pretty much winning
material i have this move now
[Music]
i want to play this move
let me start with this
there's rook a4 queen c5
and g7 hangs but then this move
this could be the last game that counts
for the tournament
the bishop e6
it's still kind of weird
i'm gonna play b5 here
it looks wrong but i'm gifting a pawn to
get the knight here
now that looks a bit misplaced
hopefully
king can always find safety maybe
take this
well it's still tricky
i don't know why i just did that
oh that's not a good decision
okay i'm playing really risky right now
okay so here i check and take
x tricks
okay so now i'm up a bishop
risk it for the biscuit i'm trying i'm
trying
biscuit smells so delicious
i hope my opponent is not aware of the
tournament situation
it's not made in one
it's made next move let's go okay i won
let's go
ah opponent could have stalled
and then the game would not have counted
for the tournament
but
i think unless this person deserves wins
this person
in berserk
i think i'm safe
wow what a
game not the cleanest games but some fun
games
this last game was actually really
topsy-turvy gg that was a fun game oh
thank you destinator
okay we're waiting for the tournament to
officially end
get ready for it
wait what
hey confetti
get some more confetti
okay that was fun hello to future people
on youtube
you did it congrats on a clutch win
thanks so much